all right let's go to jake in kansas
city
you've talked in the past about people
getting addicted to self-help
that we mistakenly search for the next
hack the next optimization
strategy i felt this way in my own
experience
to self-improvement i tend to consume
all that's out there
and while i live out some of it i find
myself being more concerned with reading
or listening to the next thing whatever
that may be
so how do i go about choosing the top
three to five things i find most
valuable
and just walking that path how do you
stay committed to learning and growing
while also remaining steadfast to a
short list of pursuits that you're 100
committed to
how do we avoid consuming self-help as
an end in itself
instead of just a means to a greater end
thanks that's a great question
it goes back to analysis paralysis what
we were talking about before
whether it's the gear or self-help
literature
these are just devices to distract you
and prevent you from actually
moving forward i've got nothing against
self-help literature it helps lots of
people
you know i think it's good that it
exists in the world but i've also become
a little bit cynical about it as a
podcaster i'm now
on these lists with all the publishing
houses so i get all the galleys of all
the non-fiction books in the mail
before they come out so every week i get
like 10 self-help books in the
in the mail yes and every author wants
to come on the podcast and
after receiving like 100 of these over
the year you're like
how much self-help literature do we need
there can't be that many secrets to
getting better
and then i think about david goggins and
i'm like how many self-help books did
that guy read
you know how many he read zero he got
off his ass and he got to work
yeah right so self-help is fine
you know if you if you need some
guidance if you lacked mentorship or
education
in your life such that these are helpful
to you i think that's great but when you
start to use them as a shield
to insulate you from taking any actions
obviously they're becoming
an impediment they're the very thing
that is preventing you from helping
yourself it's interesting the irony in
that
right yeah it's interesting like this
this
fact that neuroscience has become so
popularized it kind of makes us
like attuned optimization and in this
tech world where everything's supposed
to optimize like there's a whole
like tim ferriss's kind of position and
how to optimize
like the work week or how to do this or
that um
it's uh it's interesting i think peop
there are people out there there's a
whole segment of population that are
interested in how to be optimal
but then the pursuit of that but when
you look at the most
optimal people in the world yeah they're
not the people that are focused on
optimization necessarily
so it is a weird kind of paradox i
suppose
um and i would say to jake listen
like he's like how do i go about
choosing the top three to five three
things i find most valuable and just
walking the path how about one thing
oh you know i can't tell you what your
values are but
you know if you can get clear on what
your values are
and establish something that you want to
manifest in your life
let's begin that process i think the
analysis paralysis comes in
in the plotting and the map making and
what is the trajectory and how am i
going to get there and there's so much
mental masturbation that goes into that
at the behest of taking that first step
so again i think it goes
back to simplifying this process
we want to over complicate it and think
that we have to
lay on top of our goals some crazy
lattice work
right and i think that those can become
handicaps as much as tools
it's interesting i i think about the
hubermann thing talking about like how
habits first and then thought
and perceptions and everything follow
right behavior behavior
behavior first and then everything else
follows um
and the construction of habits it sounds
like
maybe he's the type of guy that gets
bored from doing the same thing over and
over again
and there is a certain boredom in
creating a habit that becomes like a
daily ritual
but you got to stick with something
about cr like creating habits for
yourself maybe every morning coming up
with a morning practice whether it's a
meditation or a yoga
and then a meditation or something that
you commit to doing every day something
one thing that you commit to doing every
day
and then see see what that gets you as
opposed to whatever you got out of a
self-help book maybe there's some habits
that you can take that you can build
your days around
that you can lock in you know i think
that that's
good advice i would say and we talked
about this last time i think
that it's important to understand that
when you're consuming
a self-help book that that's not
the accomplishment the accomplishment is
in applying that wisdom to your life
right
and so the first step is understanding
that just because you read a book
doesn't mean that you did anything and i
think what happens is you read these
books
and you feel like you're accomplishing
something or
growing in your life simply in the
consuming of that book
but that in and of itself well it's like
in 12 step they say
[Music]
half measures will of value nothing
right so like reading a
reading a book it's good you've consumed
this this piece of knowledge but unless
you figure out how to
apply it in some fungible tangible way
in your life
it will avail you nothing right so it's
disabusing you of that notion that
you've done something just because
you've read a book and it's
reconfiguring your perspective to focus
more on
actions you know to bring it back to
huberman behavior like lead with the
behavior
so we're sitting here having a podcast
episode 500 and whatever
i didn't start the podcast because i
read a self-help book
and tried to figure out what my values
were and created some road map
to where i would be seven years later i
just thought this will be cool and i
turned on a mic
i had it was a behavior it was an action
like hey this might be fun and i was
like that was cool let's do it again
right it wasn't like a whiteboard
no situation no you know and i think
that's the problem with our
optimization obsessed culture is that we
think we have to have all of these
things
figured out before we begin and in truth
in my own personal experience
it's in the doing that the path is
revealed
yeah you never really know what the end
product is going to be and
um we don't even necessarily know what
optimal is
while we're experiencing it right it's
all
it's all kind of through analysis later
well there's also a binary nature to
that very conversation around
optimization
anyway you know i i i lean more towards
the
ethereal unknowing of it all yeah right
there's a spirituality to all of this as
well that i think gets lost in the
conversation around optimization
which is you know this assumption that
we can drill everything down to ones and
zeros
and create an equation for success and i
just don't think it works that way
that doesn't mean that we can't learn
and improve by
virtue of these tools but i think
there's a bigger
dance at play and broadening your
perspective and understanding that i
think
at least it's been helpful to me we've
talked about that before i mean just
recognizing you're a speck of
consciousness in this great sea
is liberating in a way because it means
that um
there's so much more going on that you
can possibly be aware of and if you just
handle your stuff in a systemic way
systematic way on a day-to-day basis um
it's going to get you to a good place
you just don't know where that good
place is necessarily which is also a
beautiful thing
just think about this self-esteem comes
from
esteemable acts like that's a truth
right why is that the case can that be
defined in some kind of
binary optimization vernacular
like i think it's a spiritual principle
that we are the sum total of our actions
and if we do esteemable
more than that we're more than the sum
total of our actions
but i think that that you know having a
just being able to broaden your aperture
a little bit
and understand that if you if you are
um if you are clear
in your intentions and you are full of
heart
pure of heart that when you whatever
path that you pursue
and i talked about this in my book like
they i believe that the universe will
conspire to support you
if you've done the inside work if you
are coming from
a place of love and compassion and
gratitude that the world will greet you
in kind and that has nothing to do
with you know neuroscience necessarily
you disagree i i agree to a point i
think that uh
chaos theory exists and sometimes chaos
descends
on your head well also luck plays a huge
part yeah yeah yeah so i don't think
it's
always it can always be that way but
some
but i i can say that if you tend to
greet your experiences
i do think it comes down to how you deal
with the hand you're dealt
so um sometimes you're dealt a really
shitty hand
and it's really hard to stay open and
positive about it
um but that doesn't mean that the person
who does stay open and positive about it
isn't gonna have more success than the
one that doesn't so i i think it's i
think it's complex but i do believe
you're right
a lot of the time i also believe that
chaos you know hurricanes
hurricanes brew yeah yeah and and that
does happen
point taken yeah
[Music]
you